les amis je vais pas bien non parce
qu'un jour j'ai dit
et aujourd'hui j'ai une faiblesse envers
un type de jeu que j'ai envie de faire
sur cette chaîne sur la chaîne on a déjà
fait des jeux à choix comme emilie the
way ce genre de trucs entre-temps s'est
développé un vrai business autour de ces
trucs de jeu à choix il y en a une
flopée sur le ps store je n'ai jamais vu
ça et j'en avais pas conscience avant
juin dernier lorsque je suis tombé sur
ce twitt wahba renom une fille devienne
fou en voyant l'homme de sa vie avec une
autre fille et toi deviennent rétif où
je me suis penché un peu sur le game du
mobile game est en fait plus le temps
passe et plus il ya des boîtes qui se
monte qu'il crée ce genre de jeu parce
que c'est pas facile à faire mais enfin
je veux dire le temps passé à faire ses
jeux par rapport à combien j'en étais
les charges c'est de la balle bon c'est
un peu dans la lignée des threads
confessé des histoires bon 100% fictive
est complètement comme la plupart du
temps et aujourd'hui je veux qu'on
découvre la peste d'entre elles je veux
qu'on découvre l'histoire de lédar rhin
alors ce jeu là c'est une boîte
brésilienne qu'il a fait est en fait
face au succès du jeu ils ont décidé de
le traduire pour le proposer au marché
hispanique aux marchés anglophones et
aux marchés francophones pour que nous
aussi on devienne fou avait du coup la
salorge pavé graphiquement c'est pas
moche d'offres c'est assez beau bref
annonce épisodes 1 à nouveau départ
c'est pas mon chien je vous ai dit que
c'était pas méchant
linda brown la fameuse qui est telle qu
est ce qu elle fait et qu'est ce qu'elle
veut gens sérieux rival aéroports
le début de jeu si on se fait agresser
par un mec qui a l'air un peu mégalo et
qui se croient bg qu'est ce que tu fais
là
pourquoi tu me suis alors pour des
raisons évidentes clément va ajouter des
voix au personnage puisqu'il n'a pas de
base ils vont fait bien des dessins
aller voir la flamme pécout noir ne pas
refaire lindt a annoncé un gars qu'on a
lâché parce qu'on est une femme forte et
indépendante est cuit c'est un vieux con
trop tard kevin mecheri il n'y a pas
deux mais kevin non c'est non laisse moi
tranquille kevin g un vol à prendre
voilà ça c'est bien notre avis pas de
partir linda
m et kevin kelly king kevin c'est simple
on va venir on va casser les jambes
tousse ok tu menaces pas une mince comme
ça espèce de gros chien d'un tu le
rejette violemment le rejeter poliment
mais on le rejette violemment qu'est-ce
qu'il ya un écran de puta quoi
attends médias ont bondi avec la b tous
comme ça à temps
j'ai rêvé où il allait lever la main sur
elle kevin se souviendra de la jfp que
tu es à donner a été chez qui la met au
fond
si tu ne peux pas d'ennuis je te
conseille de partir tout de suite je
m'en vais mais je te promets que ce
n'est pas fini binta même chose pour toi
crétins ou est-ce que les moyens de
celle-ci sur les expressions de visage
quand même est-ce que vous êtes blessé
mais attendez mais est-ce que c'est pas
ce mâle alpha viril qu'on a tous fait
genre d'être à mon nom dans notre vie
pour plaire à une fille oui oui oui je
peux me débrouiller tout seul
merci pour votre aide on se débrouille
tout seul mon pote on et linda bras
d'une femme forte indépendante tu crois
qu'on a besoin de toi bruno ça se trouve
tout ça avec un coup monté et est un
pote de l'autre et tu veut m'envoyer en
étant un pote de l'autre n'en attendait
peut-être que je m'emporte un peu
peut-être qu'on devrait laisser une
chance à bruno et lui faire confiance
on va le remercier pour son aide c'est
la moindre des choses je suis faible et
bien merci beaucoup je ne sais pas ce
qu'il serait arrivé sans vous nous tu
aurais eu un bleu et un traumatisme et
lui seraient en prison voilà bruno faire
à votre service
brno frère bruno frère il est dans la
fredzone avant même de savoir qu'il y
ait et bien merci beaucoup plus nous
mais j'ai un vol à prendre et je suis en
retard j'espère pouvoir vous revoir
jamais peut-être que vous aurez une
autre opportunité de me sauver
jamais ok c'est ciao monsieur votre jet
est prêt non matin des bruneaux il est
beau il est bienveillant il est riche
mais attendez mais c'est quoi ce cliché
d'homère
[Musique]
attends c'est notre maison de vacances
on n'a pas les mêmes vacances
linda je ne peux pas croire que tu sois
là ce hallucine qu'il y aille je suis si
contente c'est comme à la fac c'est
comme à la fac bella le temps est passé
ce cas la fac je te jure qu'on ne jouait
pas dans une villa comme ça alors
pourquoi on est venu voir cynthia rio
c'est quoi ce bordel tu crois vraiment
que j'aurais pu rater ton mariage
waouh je pensais pas qu'elle répondrait
si vite à ma question j'ai tellement de
temps entendre chanter à nouveau à auch
ou trop cool
vous sentez vous pas que comme par
hasard bruno yvette au mariage faisaient
ou pas c'est sûr excuses moi cynthia je
peux voir avec quoi la liste des invités
il a l'air un peu con mais je juge pas
mais là comme on dit de moi que je rêve
elle est ici linda brown ok donc on pèse
vraiment en fait on est vraiment une
tendre cela au fait je suis fan ok cool
cool tu viennes photo pour le petit
frère c'est ça parce que toi t'es pas
fan savoir juste pour ton petit frère
mais par contre quand tu prends la photo
tu as l'air de tremblay un peu d'être
content aussi
ok donc lui c'est le majordome ami et
confident de cynthia ok on veut tout ça
comment il s'appelle j'ai oublié son nom
tu dois avoir beaucoup de travail trop
aussi bio adro diot drauzou même temps
il a excusé moi droz used by renault je
reste toujours de plus après le mariage
est intéressant c'est là où va y avoir
beaucoup de petites péripéties il n'y
aura plus personne dans la maison des
méthodes et cynthia 110 mo en lune de
miel
attendez attendez j'ai l'impression que
ça va finir en plus partie à un perso
que linda bronn elle va elle va ça va
lui monter à la tête là la villa
pourquoi pas et pourquoi pas a abondé on
est des gratteurs on l'apprend la maison
alosi bien sûr aplati de faire ta
connaissance linda hockey drosos est
barrée on n'est plus qu'à et cynthia
alors qui c'est passé neuf cas kevin o
la flemme laquelle le raconte ona
flashback qu'est ce qu'il a fait ce
qu'on alors qu'il était avec la grande
et belle linda brown ne tarde pas trop
kevin on va être en retard pour le dîner
une minute j'ai presque fini ma touche
c'est quoi l'histoire
j'espère c'est très court puis sera
court plus elle est drôle au nom le
classique c'est le portable de kevin
oh non je devrais les prévenir que nous
allons être en retard ça part d'une
bonne intention ce qu'elle tentera de
faire elle va découvrir quelque chose de
si maureen à stéphanie mais qui est
cette stéphanie à elle a dit c'était
génial hier il a dit demain chez toi à
lahti codes habituels
linda que fais-tu avec mon téléphone je
ne peux pas croire que tu es recommencer
je peux pas croire que tu es recommencer
à quoi arrête de faire le surpris car
est jeune et bien fait mon amour laisse
moi t'expliquer à d'autres ados tu le
fais à d'autres qui m'a brisé le coeur
kevin ma chérie
au moins il a pas dit c'est parce que tu
crois c'est la pire phrase mec
au diable le kevin vatant d'ici ouais
voilà c'est bien mais d'accord je suis
désolé aux noms cynthia et pleure pour
nous en ont bavé star je pense j'ai
passé un moment à la plage à la loi la
plage bonne idée ça let's go qu'est ce
que c'est que ça il y à un mot qui a
bien pu l'écrire
attendez attendez quoi on vient de
changer dans nos chambres il ya le bruit
d'une boîte à musique
on l'apprend il ya un mot dedans c'est
un pas très bienvenu au brésil cherche
le collier attardé mais qui est ce grand
séducteur qui est en train de me charmer
la à tout et clichy un collier de
quelques ollier il parlait très bonne
question linda bon il aurait pu se
donner un peu plus quand même waouh ça
doit valoir une fortune qui peut bien
être derrière tout ça qui donc trop
d'émotion pour le premier jour
allons à la plage bon elle a gagné un
collier mec gratos atteint voilà c'est
pas non non non non non attendez excuses
et propose ce n'est pas ça la plage la
plage c'est ça
ça c'est la plage privée ça n'a rien à
voir
c'est une deuxième agression pour linda
ah ça y va ça les enchaîne bravo
messieurs
excellent exemple bravo en nous c'est la
fin comment évaluez vous cette épisode
mais excellent épisode de un voyage un
mariage on y va direct au tricot oh
attendez excusez moi autant pour moi ils
se connaissent je ne pourrai donc jamais
te surprendre linta je savais que
c'était toi comment vas tu attendais
c'est une petite conquête qu'on a déjà
eu à rio c'est ça l'histoire à c'était
lui la boîte à musique awe rodrigo là
les gars on prend un exemple à on veut
tous est le rodrigo d'une femme mais le
collier coûte une fortune
je ne peux pas l'accepter linda tu le
mérites puis devrait le mettre pour le
mariage
peut-être bien elle a vite changé d'avis
elle a très vite changé d'avis non mais
vraiment ça me cherche pas par l'aar est
inquiète tu peut révoquer cool merci
comme toujours plus mais ravissante je
vois dans ton petit sourire que tu veux
me pécho tout le monde qu'on voit dans
ton petit sourire que tu veux nous
prêchons tu flirt innocemment tu ne
flirte pas innocemment on peut flirter
eut pas innocent on s'en fout et on est
célibataire puisse convoquer n'en
attendait peut-être que je parle un peu
vite peut-être que je m'emporte
j'espère me bruneau toujours dans la
tête et je n'arrive pas à imaginer avec
quelqu'un d'autre que lui pour le moment
on peut pas flirter merci pour le
collier en tout cas tu te tiens quoi tu
as bien je suis toujours médecins il est
médecin voit tout le monde est beau
gosse riche et un métier prestigieux ont
leur arrivera jamais à la cheville à ces
gars là j'ai voyagé au maroc et en libye
avec médecins sans frontières au bas
elle n'était pas assez parfait faut
qu'ils aient des associations bravo wind
non au pardon rodrigo c'est super
rodrigo elle s'en bat les couilles 100%
ya pas besoin de famille se soit frère
pour que tu fasses renzo n'est quand
même allez je dois aller chercher les
alliances pour le mariage c'est chaud
à de retour à temps cette belle villa au
numéro inconnu
c'est bruno qui a réussi à avoir mon
numéro nathan mais bien venus avec un
soutien et bien sûr je réponds tu n'as
pas à ces diamants
je réponds allez hop là je suis athée le
pigeon je réponds à l'appel c'est qui
c'est bruno le système c'est bruno mon
coeur bat fort s'il te plaît ne
raccroche pas kevin non j'ai fait une
erreur linta hijo de puta super 5 euros
pour répondre à kevin mec c'est relou je
sais que j'ai tout gâché
mais notre relation est trop fort nique
ta grosse mer j'ai besoin de toi mais je
sais que toi aussi binta il se comporte
tellement commun
c'est un jeu vidéo je m'énerve vraiment
tu as été mon manager c'est tout a
insisté le manager à 6 nuls allez ciao
va trouver une autre chanteuse et ciao
kevin tous ensemble à troyes 1 2 3 c'est
chao kevin allez on dort demain c'est le
mariage
on va voir bruno c'est sûr aller
[Musique]
je suis à fond dedans
wahou quelle merveilleuse journée pour
un mariage et binta honte a dit nous
rodrigo tue trois besoins défensifs je
ne savais pas que tu étais ici tu te
rappelles au moins que cynthia et ma
soeur non ok pardon au nord on a flirté
avec le frère de notre meilleur pote
c'est terrible tu mais incroyablement
belle merci tu n'es pas mal non plus non
linda nom ne sens pas que j'ai dû faire
un compliment retour c'est pas parce
qu'il est médecin
il l'aide des associations il a de
l'argent et il est gentil comme tout ok
on sent avec lui excuse-moi rodrigo
désolée de me ranger au delà
papillonnage à ce que se demande sur les
alliances tu les as bien avec toi ou ide
rosio je les ai juste les alliances
elles ont dû tomber de ma poche c'est ça
le vrai rodrigo tant de bonnes choses
pour cacher une incompétence totale quoi
elles sont tombées
où ça oh mon dieu j'aurais payé dans ma
chambre vous faites face à un problème
majeur aller prier dans votre chambre
mais n'essayez pas de résoudre le
problème par contre asie on va l'aider
on va l'aider apparemment ils sont près
de la terrasse ont mal et d'être nicaise
a porté un toast rien par là y'a pas
d'alliance peut-être dans le sac qui est
en train de fouiller je clique sur tout
ce qui brille ça facilite un peu les
choses à regarder là bas non le classico
hommes et que le conte nommé le coup
classique
on est déçus rodrigo bon tu as de la
chance que je sois là pour t'aider
rodrigo ça c'est sûr tu viens de gagner
une promenade en ville demain quoi as tu
attends je viens de sauver la vie et
j'ai gagné un truc qui t'arrange toi
uniquement toi mais arrêtez tous
manipulés dans ce jeu bordel ciao
la cérémonie va commencer je ne veux pas
en perdre une miette
oh oui bah oui je pleure toujours à ce
moment précis du moment que d'une inonde
pas tout le monde
ce n'est pas grave c'est pas drôle
arrête ses wagons jb clair
mari et femme du coup on chante
du coup on va chanter
[Musique]
la la la la
mais t'as fait quoi c'était tout moment
linda j'arrive
non non non bruno plutôt bien mais des
monos laisse moi faire je vais l'aider
oui voilà voilà voilà voilà ça c'est
bien ça ça c'est bien c'est juste un peu
d'où je vis dans ma chambre pour me
changer si on a un qui vient dans ma
chambre pendant que je me change ça va
mal finir
attendez attendez la normale à la bam et
plus rire mon dieu quelle honte
mais non ça arrive au contraire ça trop
mignonne j'espère pouvoir trouver
quelque chose à me mettre à leur robe
mouillé sexy ou impressionnante à être
sexy c est impressionnant et c'est de
notre côté non je vous laisse méditer
quelques secondes sur moi même j'ai pas
compris ce que j'ai dit qu'on va être
impressionnante mc berry au bac c'est
vraiment ce que je veux dire c'est
carrément impressionnant et sexy allez
on y va
[Musique]
bruno ça fait vingt minutes il était
bleu au bord d'un c j'avais envie de
lâcher si j'avais su que vous seriez là
je vous aurez à mener en avion pourquoi
tu n'as pas fait parce qu'il n'avait
sûrement une autre salle o vous voulez
un verre évidemment qu'on veut à woerth
à prendre le côté le plus cher et tu vas
le payer
tout le monde vous regarde bien sûr
c'est le pouvoir de la couleur pour vous
devriez faire attention c'est la couleur
du cash et des scènes de drague
ne vous inquiétez pas je résisterai aux
tentations
si vous voulez je peux garder un oeil
sur venir ça al'air tentant one on met
attend ça séduit fort là alors bruno
dites moi qu'est ce que tu fais tu fais
quoi
que faites vous quand vous n'êtes pas en
train de me sauver a dans la vie je suis
producteur de musique non mais c'est le
destin
j'ai adoré ce que j'ai entendu de votre
chanson vous avez une voix unique
tu ne penses pas ce que tu viens de dire
et ça se voit on déjeune ensemble un de
ces jours houba samba évidemment mais
c'est bruno c'est notre cross ultime
bien sûr j'adore manger bien sûr j'adore
manger jamais navigué en réponse à une
invitation oui j'adore la nourriture et
binta au printemps toi tu pas du ballet
je t'ai trouvé facilement tout le monde
parle de tarbes
tu es vraiment belle prête pourtant
c'est avec bruno il est pas content on
allait le nil dans lego comme ça là paf
paf légaux au revoir monsieur frère au
revoir mademoiselle brown
mais non mais moi je me marre de tes
chiens chiens de forcer mec te voici
binta
non mais là le harcèlement ça suffit non
jetable est bien dit que ce n'était pas
fini
non c'est kevin hall uche emma et goûter
c'est la fin de cette vidéo est ce que
ça vous a plu j'ai adoré franchement au
bout de deux minutes j'étais dedans
j'étais vraiment de danger où j'adorais
faire ces petits vieux savané manque est
une histoire comme ça à la course red où
pour une fois c'est pas moi qui raconte
je découvre en même temps que vous alors
qu'un secrète bas je découvre en même
temps que vous c'est moi qui vous
racontent ce que j'ai déjà vu donc la
mécanique me fait du bien me fait
plaisir est ce que vous voulez une suite
oui ou non ceux qui veulent une suite
nous on va faire le classique vous
mettez un jamais vous dites un
commentaire on veut la suite on aime
bruno olala quel bel étalon et si vous
voulez pas eh ben vous dit à haute voix
comme ça devant la caméra et comme ça je
le saurai la gv l'homme question
actuellement est ce que rodrigo var
était de forcer comme jamais est ce que
bruno le chevalier blanc derrière son
sourire est en réalité un gros con
eskelina va rester forte face à tout ce
qui l'attend est-ce que je vais reperd
2,5 euros pour une [ __ ] un drop de merde
à changer de faire part à trier deux
prochaines vidéos j'ai adoré une passion
plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]